garlic in the lead-off spot because his
reputation precedes him or did in the
twins organization he punishes
left-handed pitching
driven to right field hit pretty well
going back is grossman at the wall it's
gone
kyle garlick with his first home run
and the twins jump out in front
well this is the way you want to start a
road trip after a tough home stand you
put power in that lead off spot as we
saw from kepler in the last series
swings and misses derek skuggle gets the
first out of the inning and a strikeout
of josh donaldson it just kills tigers
pitching especially in this ballpark not
this time though tarik school strikes
him out for the second straight punch
out i think it's taking away a little
bit of his fastball
sits him down looking
after the lead-off homer from garlic
scuba settles in and strikes out
donaldson cruz and garber shoemaker the
numbers aren't where he'd like them to
be but for me it's the fastball then
it's a split and it's a split again and
it's a split again one and two to scope
another pop-up this looks playable
so no with the catch
so now with a nice pickup he'll head
into a dugout full of cheerleaders
polanco's done most of his damage
against
left-handed pitching driven in
seven of his runs so
seem comfortable
there's a high fly left field hit well
badou going back and that one is gone
another lead-off home run in the second
inning
well almost right on cues you're saying
you need to get that part of the lineup
rolling and
blanco gets himself a
little hanger over the plate and
nice
seeming more comfortable two-nothing
lead here
it's either a homer or a strikeout for
terrex school so far tonight another 2-2
and a wave and a miss another strikeout
for terrex scuba he has five but
community is pulling for this guy to
get a base hit so he can breathe again
it's just been a tough one now the
payoff
drives one to deep right field over goes
kepler that ball is off the wall
cabrera jogs down to first and that
ties babe ruth for number 45 all time
and career hits with 2
873.
you know niko goodrum here's a guy that
has had his share of strikeouts you know
he's getting his hits he's getting his
strikeouts
it's kind of all or nothing with him
but
good to see him getting some multi-hit
games
that's what the tigers did well in
boston is they put together back to back
at bats there's another hit
to left center field on a line
back-to-back singles for the tigers to
start the second
[Applause]
2-2 to jones
could be two one
and two and yes the tigers are
struggling
hit hard and down the line into the left
field corner garlic continues to punish
left-handed pitching dropped by badou
and garlic will
hold up at second with a double
you've got to be able to recognize that
as a as a pitcher too i'm beating the
guy how long yes sir strikes him out
again same pitch
scuba struck out cruz in the first
check swing beautiful get over there to
cabrera
feeds scuba and a good job by tarik
skubal to avoid any damage two-nothing
minnesota
works himself with the lead off block
he'll take it and the 2-1
there's another base hit from miguel
cabrera candelario's going to be
aggressive all the way to third standing
up
well we know more to say it and there it
is he drives this ball
with authority right up the middle and
great base running by jamer candelario
and now he stands alone at 45 breaking
the tie with the great babe ruth
that's what he wanted the strikeout
now a full count to willy castro
the strikeout
[Applause]
for right field
and that's a nice job by shoemaker
getting out the mop on the bucket
cleaning up his own mess
89th pitch and his seventh strikeout of
the game
his high
has been 90 so he's getting right up
there
here's the one two swing and a miss
eight punch outs for scuba so far
tonight
changed eye levels in those last two
pitches through the fastball up and away
then he buries the slider down and in
that's the back footer that one works
fly ball to right grossman's there he's
got it terence school has tied a career
high in strikeouts set a career high in
pitches and he's been pretty darn good
through five they're gonna at least put
the tarp on
for now
and hope that this
wet cell
will pass not too long of a delay
do a two-hopper to donaldson
one away
swing and a miss two strikeouts there
goes grossman swung out of the missed
his strike three
and
that will complete the strikeout brian
garcia in for the 12th time this year
hopefully he will uh keep the twins in
check
the 3-1
and he walks in
and he walks sono
back-to-back free passes issued by brian
garcia
and now kepler will bat with two men
aboard
and into center field of base hit
polanco around third and he will score
kepler delivers an rbi single sending
cino to third base
chopper
and they will get the out there and a
run will score sono coming in from third
base
no cave with a fly ball to center
and jacoby jones ends the inning
and now stachak will pitch to candelario
cabrera and goodrum
counts in his favor right now
driving one to right and a base hit for
jamer candelaria we're getting so used
to that he got a pitch to hit
inside to cabrera
he's on base for a third time tonight
another chance for willy castro to get
back on track
drives one to deep left field way back
it goes that ball is gone
a home run for willie castro
that'll bust out of the slump
tigers
are on the board
14 hits on the season for a keel but do
well one two on its way
drives deep right field that is a bullet
and that ball is off the wall
but due's going to hustle to second he's
in there with a pop up slide double
one and two to grinder
and that will end it
but the tigers despite three strikeouts
get three runs as we begin play in the
seventh inning we've had two rain delays
of some substance here hopefully uh
cisnero can hold them down
and donaldson down the line might have
cracked his back but he's got a hit
and he will round first and dig for
second base
and he is in with a stand-up double
check to swing that time
and he did draw the walk first and
second two down and now polanco
a drive to right field headed to the
corner down for a hit and by the right
fielder grossman
donaldson scoring
garver to third he'll be held there
polanco
drops a double down the right field line
and the twins now lead by two they play
him to pull
god instead
cisnero takes care of it himself
but minnesota adds another one and it'll
be a lefty kepler
a high fly to right field he tees off
and has another home run way back into
the seats in right
he said right handed left hand it
doesn't matter when i'm going good i can
hit anybody and he absolutely crushed
this ball little fastball on the inside
part of the plate nice short swing just
took the barrel to it no extra no wasted
movement in that swing and
another big add-on run right here
he'll take a walk instead
and polanco will go to first with a walk
first and second and now
that'll bring up cino
sano with a liner to left a base hit
donaldson to third he's being waved
around
and sono delivers an rbi single a big
two out hit and the twins lead by four
hit well to center
and right there is jake cave and the
twins open up the road trip with a nice
win in detroit